let's go next to our caller from the
seven eight six area code who's on the
phone today from seven eight six and
where are you calling from
hello yeah that's you hi I'm Steve from
Miami hey Steve what's going on
good I had two questions - well the fact
that Democrats are really basically
doing nothing and last election we had a
huge turnout don't you think it's gonna
backfire and these people who actually
elected I mean voted for the first time
they're gonna be so turned off that
they're not gonna vote why hold on
people that voted when for the first
time in the last election 2016 or 2018
no 18 okay people who turn they voted
for the first time in 2018 yeah huge
amount of Democrats voted for the first
time in 2018 right and they might be
turned on by what by the fact that the
Democrats are really not even going to
impeachment hearings okay so so that's a
very specific so first you said
Democrats aren't doing anything now
you're saying they're not doing
impeachment hearing I'm talking yeah but
they're that's basically nothing I mean
well hold on what it let's let's get
back to impeachment in a second
what is it Democrats in the House could
have done so far that they haven't done
well the fact that they did impeachment
hearings they would you know all these
subpoenas that are being rejected and
all that yeah would it be a different
instance okay and then the public I mean
I don't know if you watched what's a
Republican that actually said he should
be impeached just in an app there was a
woman okay there was a woman in there
who was really like oh the mobile report
it said nothing because she really
didn't know at the end of what you know
she heard from him she was her eyes were
open she's like oh I didn't know that
because all she does listen to you know
the garbage on socks and all that oh if
there were impeachment hearings held it
would push out a lot of the facts in the
Muller report to the general but I agree
with you so let's say separately should
know that yeah so I agree I think
it's time for Democrats in the house to
start impeachment debate there's I agree
with you completely
I don't think now here's the thing if
you believe that impeachment debate
should start you probably don't want
Trump to be President so I don't think
that if Democrats don't hold impeachment
hearings you're going to skip voting for
someone other than Trump in 2020 I just
don't think it falls I don't mean that
but there may be a lot of people that
will okay
I mean that this so you're asserting
that I'm not I've seen no evidence to
suggest that I mean I think I looked at
the margin he won by it was so slim yes
okay so the fact that they you know the
Democrats got a lot of new voters okay
basically I think I'm I'm assuming I'm
not gonna say it for sure it was
basically because they wanted Trump out
it was an anti-trump vote it for a lot
of people it was sure right so if they
lose those people gives they say you
know what the Democrats do nothing okay
so I'm not gonna lose my votes worth
nothing because I put somebody in power
to do something they do nothing all
right
well listen I hope you're wrong you may
be right okay no data specifically but I
will certainly look into it more so I'm
gonna let you go is the echo and what
speakers and really seems to start it oh
boy if you love learning new things you
probably want to check this out the
David Pakman show today is sponsored by
Skillshare and we're giving you two
entire months of free access to
Skillshare when you click the link
underneath this video Skillshare is a
vibrant online learning community
offering more than 25,000 video classes
on just about anything you can think of
get better at playing an instrument
learn to use Photoshop how to edit
videos they have classes on drawing
painting business cooking nutrition
personal productivity and I'm not even
really scratching the surface I recently
took a great class on introductory
watercolor painting I'm still not good
but I am learning and you can access the
entire library of fun easy-to-use online
courses for free for two months by using
the link under
this video two months of learning
something that's totally new to you
something you want to get better at
something you already love or you can
get ahead in your career by learning new
skills that will help you at your job
I've gotten a ton out of it
Pat has taken some courses that he's
found really valuable and I think you'll
love it to get started for free by
clicking the link under this video